I'm joined today by Susan Bordeaux media
critic cultural historian and feminist
scholar her latest book is the
destruction of Hillary Clinton Susan
it's so great to talk to you and I found
as I as I read the book there's so much
in the book that I agree with but I also
found that there were some aspects of
what happened in the 2016 election that
were just sort of not discussed in the
book at all and we'll get to that
so let's first lay it out sort of at the
top level for our audience what do you
see as having been responsible for
Hillary Clinton's loss in November
okay central question well I think that
probably was different in my account
from many of the other accounts that are
currently dominant is actually it is
multifactorial I think there's no one
thing that made the difference I think
there are a number of things that
altogether contributed to what I call a
massive pile on that made core Me's
final announcement something that she
couldn't get over in other words it was
not the absolutely decisive event but it
was fatal because of everything that had
gone before and that includes stuff
during the primary it included the way
the media recorded her it includes a lot
of you know undercurrents of
long-standing gender ideas and
inevitably crept in it included this
email scandal the Russian interference
there's so much that impacted that
election that it's impossible to come up
with one factor that was decisive when
you look at the primary of the
Democratic Party which involves not only
Bernie Sanders but also the Democratic
National Committee which we now know was
actively working to help Hillary Clinton
be the eventual nominee what's your
assessment there of how that impacted
the eventual election between Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton well I think
that it it had a residue that was
extremely important
and the residue was to have branded
Hillary Clinton in a certain way that um
had a tremendous impact especially on
young people who you know for for
completely legitimate reasons had not
lived through certain events and who
were more dependent upon Bernie Sanders
and his surrogates to define Hillary for
them and I think that he defined her in
certain ways that though they began
really pretty innocuously
they began to tip over at a certain
point in the primary into something very
close to the she's a criminal that we
heard from the right-wing so there was a
kind of melding of the left and right
branding of Hillary that I think was
very powerful yeah I'd like she'll or
that in a little more detail if we can I
mean so I'm thinking of I'm thinking
back to the primary and I remember you
had Hillary Clinton and the DNC both
working to basically keep attention off
of Bernie Sanders as much as possible
this included the scheduling of very few
debates this including the scheduling of
debate Sunday nights on three day well
hold on I'll give you a chance to tell
me where I'm wrong
this included the scheduling of debates
on Sunday nights on three-day weekends
when many people would be traveling
really anything that could be done to
give as little attention to anyone other
than Hillary Clinton as possible but
your sense is that that Hillary Clinton
was actually the one who was damaged by
the by the primary help me understand
that okay yeah I will um well first of
all uh Bernie Sanders one of the things
you know the DNC is one issue and I
absolutely agree that the DNC was behind
everything okay good I might happy on
the specifics of it I think that the
number of debates that were scheduled
were equivalent the number of debates
that have been scheduled and passed I
think that the particulars that they
that the DNC were charged with don't
always hold up but let's get
a particularly well what's what but I
want it on my show I like to when an
assertion is made I want to follow it
through which particular assertion about
the DNC that has been made do you find
to have been not true okay well let's
take the idea that which I agree with
that the DNC was behind when Hillary
Clinton met ask why if that's the case
why Bernie Sanders wasn't a Democrat to
begin with he wasn't independent
Hillary Clinton had a long history of
working cooperatively and
collaboratively with members of the
Democratic Party which Bernie didn't
have so she had a history relationship
I mean of the way it has been presented
the way I think a lot of Bernie people
took it was it was this conspiracy
against well no I don't think I have to
go to conspiracy but what you said you
know what you said is basically because
of Hillary Clinton's historical
relationship with the people running the
DNC that's why the DNC wanted her to win
isn't that the definition of cronyism
you could call it cronyism or you could
call it you know decades of working
together with people in a way that
allowed them to feel listened to
included that allowed them to feel that
this was a leader that would be able to
embrace a large tent
for all that he has many sterling
qualities have no record of being able
to do that is that true though I mean
dating all the way back to being a mayor
in Vermont being in the House of
Representatives and all of the
committees he participated in there
being a senator I mean certainly there's
on paper fewer candidates that were more
qualified than Hillary Clinton I was one
of the first to admit it I mean her
record whether you agree or disagree
disagree with reviews it's hard to find
someone with more experience than
Hillary Clinton but to call Bernie
Sanders inexperienced also doesn't
really seem right I mean we're talking
about a guy who's been in politics for
50 years
yeah he's establishment which of course
he did not ever own he's bailing
you know for decades and decades and
decades but in terms of him spearheading
efforts in the Senate now if I can't
speak to him as mayor of Vermont I
cannot be you know he may have been a
fabulous mayor but in terms of his
ability to work in the larger arena of
Congress he does kind of very
distinguished records now I don't think
that disqualifies him but I do think
that when you look at Hillary's record
people knew her they knew herself and
when they could work with and ignore
someone who they could pass bills were
burnt ran in you can't have it both ways
you can't cuz run as an outsider and at
the same time claim that you are just as
respected and have just as good a record
of working with people as your so-called
establishment Kansas well in terms of
being respected he did have a higher
favorability rating than Hillary Clinton
so at least some people did respect him
more right
well well well what I were talking about
people in Congress masks okay fair
enough talk if we're mark mark mark is
moving to talk about the public birds
never tried you know Hillary was the
target she was the person to beat she
was the person that the GOP from the
very beginning thought they had to take
down if Bernie had ever gotten himself
in a position nothing bad whatever I
mean think about the in the onslaught of
fur scandals and nasty epithets and the
way Hillary was dragged through the mud
I mean you can go back farther than just
this collection yeah although burning
also I mean think Bernie was fighting in
a way against both Hillary and the DNC I
mean when when the leaked emails
revealed that Clinton staffers and DNC
staffers were thinking of making
Bernie's lack of religion and issue
that's pretty low right I mean that
that's pretty bad to be going on within
the Democratic Party
Bernie himself
except and I'm sorry I can't quote it
exactly because I don't have my book in
front of me that everything that they
found in the DMC email they would find
similar things in their campaign you
know had they lived in them
Bernie himself it was burning surrogates
and followers who were so upset about
those you know burn himself said goes
out in campaigns all the time people do
opposition research they're ready to
come up with dirt and in fact the
Republicans I mean I shudder as a Jew I
shudder to think of what would have
happened if the GOP had gotten their
hands on Bernie Sanders I mean we even
saw anti-semitic overtones in their
attacks on Hillary you know with those
posters with dollar signs
oh absolutely listen and as and as
someone who's Jewish myself but believe
me I'm fully following every aspect of
that line of reasoning that you're
suggesting so to sort of put a fine
point on the DNC part you've you
initially said you sort of understand
why the DNC would would help Hillary
Clinton but then you've also said that
it sounds like to me that you don't
actually think that what the DNC did
really had that much of a impact in
hurting Bernie Sanders so what what's
your sort of what's your net assessment
of what the DNC did what they did in
terms of supporting Hillary yes even
though they claim to be an unfair an
unbiased arbiter of the primary we know
they were helping Hillary Clinton what's
your sort of net assessment of well I
ultimately you know Debra Wasserman
Schultz you know quest or was asked to
resign yeah so I think the DNC
ultimately owned that they had at least
one person who had behaved in
inappropriate ways I think that on that
balance you know when you look at what
was going for Hillary and was going for
Bernie in the primary now I think that
um what the DNC did for Hillary was
I mean it's apples and oranges it's very
hard to compare because what Bernie had
going for him
was not the establishment support that
Hillary had going for her but what he
had was um a an election how can I put
this but this election both in terms of
the Republicans and off of the Democrats
really favored the candidates who could
spell bind a crowd the candidates who
could be photographed at mass rallies
the candidates who spoke in you know
one-line bursts that were electrifying
and both Bernie and Trump in his way
were that kind of campaigner hillary by
her own admission is not you know she
had said herself I really don't like to
meet you for them
I like sermon and in fact when Hillary
has been a servant
that's opposed to a campaign or her
approval rating set higher than Bernie
overwork we like and then you can argue
that there's a little bit of gender
stuff going on there we are comfortable
with women when they are in service
positions when they seem to be too
ambitious right it becomes strident
if it turns people off and the very
style I think that Bernie electrified
people with would not have gone over
lowest hillary at the same time
Hillary's own style was not favored so I
think that energy was at a lot of
disadvantages even without getting into
the way the press treated her the GOP
and the locker up and the phony
email scandal um and in my book I
approve you know that's completely she
neither lied you know I'm not you know I
know some people have have called this
butcher to kind of idolatry of Hillary
and you know I am I admire her break you
yeah
and part of the reason I think was book
may come off that way
because what we've seen is this orgy of
Hillary blaming and my feeling was yes
is just way out of proportion I could
write a book in which I said okay on the
one hand Hillary did this wrong and on
the other hand she did this but
everybody was doing the blaming for me
right yeah and I so I think that in fact
the scales were really unfairly tipped
against er even given the establishment
support that she had during the primary
well there's so much more we could talk
about unfortunately we are behind our
time and I hope to have you back
certainly more disagreements I would
love to talk with you about but I think
it's an interesting conversation
nonetheless we've been speaking with
Susan Bordeaux who's author of the book
the destruction of Hillary Clinton
thanks so much for talking to me today
thank you David Evans reddit